[Music]
creeping while you're sleeping
it's Thursday you're down but chained
out [__] always on top of your
game even if it's Thursdays you got your
uncle Joey on deck here oh [__] oh [__]
get ready to rock [__] oh [__]
greetings [__] uncle Joey here
the cloud is out but who gives a [__]
the sun shining in that sack and in your
heart will brighten your [__] day and
then includes anybody else what do we
got today I'm smoking this [__] that
louis c.k smoked before he jumped off in
front of the two chicks so get ready to
[__] go to jail today who gives a
[__] jackets Thursday the 16th of
November and the most important thing is
today is you [__]
so grab your ball salute the flag and
tell them more to suck your dick we're
gonna [__] town we got some
tremendous reefers today we got the
[__] white cookies whatever the
[__] blue cookies I got some leftover
chocolate chunk and I got [__] the
louis c.k we do this [__] but what are
you gonna do let's load up this [__]
boat get this body started [__]
went to the premiere at Coco last night
with my daughter I had a great time four
and a half the 3d glasses I had a couple
[__] boots roots in me so I was a
little like [__] looking at dragons
you [__] but it's a great move you got a
chance to take your kids go see them
[__] movie Coco
and don't forget late-breaking news Nova
December 3rd 4th and 5th December 3rd
I'm opening up the remain brother mr.
Weil Walker jr. 20 our tickets at the
Novo club downtown
Monday night the observatory in San
Diego 20 on tickets myself and weevil
Walker jr. and Tuesday night in Santa
Ana
I'm the observatory you can't [__]
loose we have a tremendous [__] time
a little country music a little dirty
word somebody's gonna get their discs up
and it ain't Harvey Weinstein you know
I'm saying don't forget tonight we got a
podcast maybe this afternoon
keep your eyes open cuz you never know
you always gotta be tip-top Magoo ready
to sling dick and shove it down
somebody's [__] earlobes look at that
that's how you [__] smoke some reefer
on a Thursday morning [__] but
never fear
uncle Joey's here we still got two more
bowls to go so you got a go tip-top see
you later [__] I'm smoking we
will my real [__] family here the
savages that don't give a [__] about the
piss test
little [__] smoke signals if an
Indian don't show up nobody will you
follow me but anyway now we're gonna
bust out some of this blue cookie again
perennial on point with some
[__] will sativa indica high
bred just to get both sides of the head
going you gotta get the yang and the
[__] yang and I'm saying and that's
the way it is I went to acupuncture
yesterday I cleaned out the [__]
coconut I cleaned out the lungs the
adrenals the gallbladder with a THC gets
all [__] sticky you follow me you got
a run with Chinese people from time to
time they don't [__] around they know
exactly how to do it that's why I'm
still I want the Chinese people wouldn't
[__] be here between the spare ribs
and the acupuncture who's better than me
did you see the mad flavor lighter
Jenica my girl up in [__] San
Francisco always putting stuff together
the real true are this tea I'm just the
[__] fat [__] that says dirty
judgment Joey what's with the chili
channel I smoke another [__] pipe I
gotta go back to work I listen all the
boss and Tom the suck you take you're
taking over the joint today right you
don't give a [__] about all this you
give orders the [__] out of you're like
Tony an 84 orders anyway two down one
the Gulf and then you go on your merry
way
a few people want to micro does huh I
don't periscope with Joey because I
microdose you might avoid some goat
cheese and spread [__] it's almost
over for you anyway [__] mic broke
dose don't make me go over there do
[__] up things to you now when I try
this chocolate chunk this that have you
[__] do the indica last time I smoked
this I was falling asleep in jiu-jitsu
tremendous I got jiu-jitsu tag on a
couple meetings we got the podcast and
that's it
ain't doing dick the rest of the week
night tomorrow night is date night with
momma and then God knows what's gonna
happen on [__] Friday and I said
[__] you know we're here
there's the best part of my day when I
get to communicate with the only [__]
family I have in the [__] the world
that you savages remember I'm with you
you're with me and they want to be with
us cuz we got it going on where
everybody else is jumping up and down
with these are the [__] mooks you and
I know what he sees is coming that's the
way you want to do it everybody else is
laughing we got our hands up Monalisa
skirt finger a banging of the death you
follow i'm santi joey which with the
Mona Lisa references Li memo
oh [__] I'm ready I had my little
Harnett acai milkshake today some ice
cubes little water and 32 grams of
[__] protein ready to rock [__]
so I [__] around today I'm
bulletproof I took my little alpha brain
for the coconut and I also got my little
[__] shrimp deck ready for jiu-jitsu
nothing like a cardio but what do you
like do you take a pill he said to
breathe for [__] 10 minutes then I
die the rest of the class but I don't
give a [__] does that keep showing up
you follow me that's the [__] key
and that's it and that's that brother
Irvine sold out all I got left is the
wheeler Walker shows la San Diego or
[__] San Hannah and then we got
Sacramento to punch line which Saturday
nights already probably sold out we got
Friday and Thursday night tickets
available beside that you know I love
your [__] without you I'd have
all got nothing as far as my Cuban
compatriots and all my little Latin
Americans or you that didn't get my
mother like bingo I'm sorry they didn't
get her sister who was he that I've had
a lot on time tongue touch go get with
the front column Oh Rhonda I ever get
through you and completing their boating
anyway I love you [__] don't
take nothing from nobody and listen it's
all about you today all these
[__] could suck your [__]
dick and call you shorty you were born
in 1940
don't forget podcasts tonight we'll be
ready to rock stay black uncle Joey
loves you
let's do one more [__] hit what was
the problem Olivier like a [__]
orphan child
twenty two push-ups write your goals and
notation for nobody
I see how old I'll see your
[__] tonight the Churchill
what's happened now